i'm jack moffitt i work for
mozilla research and i work on the lead
on the servo project which is a new
experimental web browser that we're
building and if you're wondering where
the inspiration of the name came i tried
to make it really obvious on the slide
where our sense of humor lies
so servo has a lot of goals one of them
is to be a moderate
modern browser engine whatever that
means and i'm going to hopefully
explain that to you so on the same pages
that we are
lots of technology suffers from path
dependence meaning that
decisions that you make about
implementing that technology
affect the future specifically
decisions that you make a long time ago
in the past about the implementation
affect the decisions that you make today
even though those old decisions are
completely irrelevant
browsers of course are entirely path
dependent current browsers
were designed 15 years ago
the whole landscape was different you
had different hardware
it was all single cores it was you know
slower
now we have lots more cores they're a
little bit faster
the standards were different you had css
was not supported in some of the early
browsers a lot of the stuff that we have
now that sort of
baked in we think of as the web just
didn't exist audio
video we have new standards arriving
every day
like http 2. javascript was way
different
before it was just kind of like this
little toy you could use to make things
scroll across the screen or check your
form fields for validation
now we have real apps that we write in
javascript we write games in javascript
it's become a pretty fundamental piece
of what we think of as the web
the whole web itself was different i
mean it used to be you would surf the
web right you would be reading one site
and there would be like a little web
ring and it would take you to links to
other sites that were kind of similar
and you would
read and now we use it completely
differently we have word processors that
we use there we live there
we have whole operating systems that run
on phones that are made out of the same
technology
and the security was way different so
back then we didn't worry about attacks
like
your defense against an attack against
your some web application was
making sure they couldn't ftp into your
server and replace the files
and now you have to make sure that they
can't
you know steal data from your client or
use your browser to attack some other
target or run
arbitrary code on your machine so
what pieces these are all things that
are completely different and so what
pieces
from this path dependent uh
route that the browser's evolved over
can we change or
or or can we throw away you know some
examples of this
are script parsing and execution you
have to when you parse an html page as
soon as you hit a script
you basically have to execute the script
and stop parsing and you can't actually
continue parsing until the script is
finished
and this is kind of baked in to the
specs sites depend on this and if you
change it things break
um so we can't change that unfortunately
um
native widgets used to be really
important right form like the original
versions of safari or maybe even current
ones had
form fields that looked just like all
the other os x buttons these days nobody
cares because
you know the whole operating system is
in the web and if it looks like osx
doesn't matter but there are real
technical decisions that have to be made
to work around all these issues with
integrating native widgets
it's just one example we have sync
versus async apis
we used to do everything synchronously
now we do lots of stuff asynchronously
it would be nice to have some of those
asynchronous apis
for the web and we have lots of things
that we can't fix another example is
floats
you can't really paralyze layout with
floats if we were designing this again
today we would probably fix that so
servo wants to fix some of these things
we want to target a sort of modern
web i guess you could call it and of
course we're starting from scratch
like almost literally from scratch
with the one caveat that we're very
aware of what others have done this is
a project inside mozilla we have lots of
layout engineers and rendering
engineers and all kinds of other
engineers that you need to make browsers
in mozilla
they all remember mistakes that they
made and we get to profit from their
advice
there are at least two other big browser
engines that are also open source that
we can learn from
and interact with those teams and we
need to implement
enough of a web browser that we can
experiment and find out you know
which of these ideas are good and which
of them won't work at all
but we can't implement so much of a web
browser that we have the same problem
that current browsers have which is it's
too hard to change we can't run
experiments because
there's six million lines of code to
have you have to update to change your
mind on this one decision
current browsers are so large that you
know it makes it really hard to
experiment with them
so we need to do something new or at
least we feel that way
the goal is to explore and experiment we
want to try
what are the new ways that we can solve
problems you know what
kinds of new optimizations can we find
while we solve them can we parallelize
stuff
how much of the stuff can we parallelize
can we parallelize it without breaking
what the web currently does
what can we gain if we do break the web
in specific ways in order to gain
more parallelism for example what new
technologies can we invent
that will help us parallelize more of
the web in the future
for instance if there is is there a new
api we can introduce or a new image
format or something
that would solve a large cost of
problems for people can we design a
safer browser
right now uh whenever you implement some
dom api in gecko or
in chrome or any of these other large c
plus plus code bases
you know small security bugs and these
sort of incidental apis off to the side
can have huge ramifications because if
you can exploit a bug in one piece of
the code then
generally you have access to the rest of
it modulus sandboxing
and the other thing is can we make
browsers easier to create and modify
an example of this is if you want to add
a new dom api in a browser
or add a new layout property you have to
touch a lot of code
and you have to be really confident that
it's right
and a lot of people have to look over
your shoulder to make sure you're not
doing something dumb
and so hopefully we can make that easier
too
and we're also experimenting by using
this new also a mozilla research project
a language called rust which is you know
for fast concurrent and safe programming
now we try to have the same performance
profile as c
plus and we think we're pretty close
we're also memory safe which means you
don't have null pointers
and you can't uh dereference a pointer
that's already been freed you can't
accidentally use uninitialized memory
all of these things that are
you know big huge problems in c plus
plus can happen
uh when you're programming in the safe
language of rust
or at least we hope they can't happen we
also have
you know sort of high level concurrency
abstractions so
rust has tasks that you can use which
are kind of like lightweight threads
and tasks can communicate with message
passing
and so some of the questions that we
have here are is this enough to write a
safe browser like are these abstractions
uh enough to get the job done does it
make it easy to write
parallelism for mere mortals where you
don't have to have 17 people
checking your code and decades of bug
fixes
um and of course if the answer to any of
these questions are no like rust is an
experiment as well it's sort of in a
feedback loop with
the browser itself and so if we find you
know that rust isn't up to the task we
change
rust just like we change servo
so i think the one of the main
motivations
of the project and the reason we focus
so much on parallelism
is if you look at this uh image this is
a pinterest board
there certainly seems to be a lot of
parallelism on the web right each of
these images is completely independent
you can
decode it independently each of these
little blocks with little comments and
stuff is all independent
there's no reason that interaction or
changes in one of these blocks really
affect
anything that's going on with another
block
but current browsers certainly don't
treat the web this way they're all
serial
so let's talk a little bit about what
the current browsers are doing
so how many of you know how browsers
work i certainly didn't before i started
this so
you're not alone this is a sort of
high-level diagram of what happens
so you have uh you know you type in the
url to your web browser it's going to
load the page
parse the page and it constructs a data
structure called the dom tree which
probably many of you are familiar with
and once we have a dom tree
we have to figure out we have to
calculate all the layout stuff so where
do these things actually end up on the
page
so we run all these calculations we end
up with a list of stuff to draw on the
screen
once we have a list of stuff we can draw
on the screen we can hand it to
something
to draw it on the screen and that point
we can kind of wait for user interaction
and things to happen so we wait for
things to happen the user does something
like clicking on a link or
or moving the mouse around or any of
these things
these create javascript events and the
script executes
it does all kinds of things one of the
kinds of things it does is to modify the
dom tree
and once you modify the dom tree now you
go all the way back around the loop
now you want this to be really really
fast and there's two ways to make this
fast
one is that you cannot go all the way
around the loop you can skip parts
so for example if you modify the dom
tree
and you're calculating layout you don't
necessarily
if you're in a loop you kind of want to
batch up all your layout changes
into one big piece to render so you just
go back to running more javascript
and and cut out the essentially the
bottom half of this
and the other way you can make it fast
is to make in each individual component
very fast and the main way you do this
is by doing everything
incrementally so if you make changes to
the dom tree we don't calculate layout
for the whole dom tree
you'd only calculate layout for the bits
that changed and similarly for a display
list you figure out what changed since
the old display list and you can try to
render just
little tiny sections that change so you
do things incrementally
but as you can see this is a big loop in
terms of
you know what's sort of the programming
interface to this is it looks like this
right script is running
it makes some changes layout runs and
script is running layout runs
so there's a big problem with this and
it's just a single threaded thing
it all goes by itself so if you think
about
how you might improve this you might
have some interesting ideas
we had some of these ideas
and we decided it might be a good idea
to run script and layout
at the same time like this is
one of the big experiments that we're
doing we're not sure if it's going to
work
but we're pretty confident that we're
onto something here and we think it's
really important
so this makes the diagram just a little
bit different
so now you run script it generates some
you know
dom changes so you need to calculate
layout but as soon as you trigger like
you know
the calculation of layout you just go
back to running script again
it's great so now you have you know
essentially two times the performance
maybe
of course this doesn't always work
because we have these nasty things in
javascript
uh that read information that's layout
based
so you have get uh get client bounding
rect
or bounding client record i guess which
basically says you know hey i have this
element where is it on the screen
in order to figure out where it is on
the screen of course we have to run all
the layout calculations
so we won't be able to continue script
execution until we have the data
but performance wise it seems like this
could potentially be a big win
and implementation wise it turns out
it's really simple
um and i'll show an example of why that
is in a little while
with uh when we see partial layout so
this is the main
one of the main experiments so there's a
problem here
which is if you have layout and script
going at the same time they have the
shared data structure
the dom that they both have to operate
on they're actually both reading it
and writing it the javascript code
is you know reading it to see what the
values or properties are and writing it
to set new values and properties
the layout code obviously has to read a
lot of these properties to figure out
where stuff goes on the screen
and it also propagates the style
information and all kinds of stuff
throughout the data structure so it's
also writing to there
and a big constraint here is we're
competing with the performance of single
threaded browsers
so it's not enough here just to say oh
we're going to put some locks on here
and that way no two threads can be
modifying the same node for example or
or you know even an atomic uh you know
lock free data structure
has performance implications um that
probably won't get us
in the same ballpark of performance as a
native browser which doesn't have to do
sort of any
any of these things it can just treat
the data
however likes um and of course we need
it to be safe
you know we can't just race on all this
data and hope that everything works
we want some kind of guarantees or
assurances that it'll be good
example of this is you know if script is
making changes to element style say you
set the background color to red
and then you set the text color to black
or something like that
if you um if you if you don't handle
this case properly you might render
the intermediate state here where in a
in firefox or
or chrome you would see a node that has
you know
some properties before and then a
background property of red and a text
property of black
you know you might see it might change
to red first and then change the text
color
so we don't want that also if script was
going through and deleting nodes
layout might be running calculations
that needed that information and then of
course you might crash
or something else about what happened so
the thing we are
doing to try to solve this problem we
call the copy on right dom
so the key thing here is that layout
always sees the same
data structure the same version of the
data structure this is always going to
be layout's view of it is going to be
blue
in these next couple of slides and
this blue data structure is effectively
immutable
as far as layout could be concerned or
really layout can write to it
but it but it can't see any changes that
happen
from other parts of the system so
imagine now that
we have some javascript code and it
wants to change the a
the a node to have a red background
color
so what does that look like so we copy
the a node to a new node
totally independent layout can't see it
and then we change there's two sets of
pointers for all of the nodes one is a
clean set of pointers that layout
c's and traverses and the other is the
dirty set of pointers that script can
manipulate
so here script has added a dirty pointer
to a child
to point to a and a has a pointer back
to the original piece of the tree which
hasn't changed
so layout still sees the same version of
the tree script now has a version of the
tree it can work on
and everybody's happy so what happens if
we keep going like if we change the
child of a
we copy you know that node and we have
the pointers updated
so now there's sort of this extra
version of the tree hanging off to the
side
and this keeps going for as many changes
this script needs to make
and now what happens is at the end this
layout will
will have completed running and so
before it starts the next version of
layout
we basically remove the old nodes of the
tree
and we take the dirty ones and we change
you know we basically copy all the
values and the dirty pointers to the
clean pointers and now we have a new
version of the tree
and this will be the new sort of
immutable version of tree that layout
will see
and now script can go off and do its
thing
again and we think this should be pretty
fast
so how is how do we make this safe
so rust type system is sort of a key
ingredient in enforcing the safety of
these operations
essentially underneath the covers
there's one data structure in memory
but it's exposed as two different
structures or
you know two different objects in the
type system
and each of these different objects has
different methods and different fields
that it can look at
and the compiler can essentially
statically guarantee that you're not
you know doing something you shouldn't
be doing
leaks are pretty much not allowed and
and
nodes can't really escape
which helps which helps make sure you're
not doing the wrong thing
okay so that's the cow dom we call it
now let's talk about parallel layout
so before we can talk about parallel
layout
probably uh better start with how lay
you know how layout works in the current
browsers um current browsers
and servo has this as well they have
this parallel data structure in gekko
it's called the frame tree i think in
webkit it's called the render tree
in servo we call it the flow tree it's a
parallel data structure
that sort of links back to the dom and
has essentially
you can think of it as like the
containing blocks of the page are
represented here
and when you want to calculate layout
information you basically start at the
top and you say you know layout and the
way gecko does this is
essentially a c plus virtual function
call that says you know it
talks to all its kids and says go do
your layout and then the kids talk to
their kids and say go do your layout
now the thing here is because it's just
a virtual method call
you know all of those virtual methods
all these implementations of go you know
go do layout
can access any part of the tree they
want they can do whatever they want they
can look at their parents they can look
at their children they can look at their
grandchildren they can look at their
grandparents
they can reach all the way over
somewhere in another sub tree and check
out what's over there
this makes it almost impossible to
parallelize
because you have no idea how the data is
being accessed
so and because these traversals can do
anything there's nothing in the c plus
plus type system or
the implementation that prevents you
from doing this stuff
it gets done all over the place so it's
kind of a bit of a mess
so in servo we have a separate data
structure as well called the flow tree
but our traversals are quite different
and we we sort of
our goal is to design this structure
such that it makes the traversals really
simple and easy to express
and easy to parallelize so this is what
our traversals look like
they're they're in servo they're on the
flow tree i'm just showing the dawn tree
here because it's
easier you have three passes
you basically go from the bottom up and
you say okay i know how big i'm supposed
to be
tell my parent and you know it collects
all those and goes up so you bubble up
these like sort of
preferred and intrinsic width to the top
of the tree once you have all those you
can go back down and say okay now that i
know what everything
wants how everything wants to be sized i
can actually assign it
some width and then once you get all the
way back to the bottom you go back up
and assign the height
so and then once you're at the once
you're at the top and you assign the
height for the
page then you're done so when these
kinds of traversals are easy to
parallelize for example in a top-down
case
you can just spawn a new task for all
your children and they can spawn new
tests for all their children
and so on and so forth and and the
bottom-up traversal also
can be parallelized
now there's an issue here like as i said
before floats can't really be paralyzed
so if you have sort of a subtree of
these things that has floats in it
then you actually have to walk that in
order because if if you have
one node that's floating then it kind of
affects you know how wide the
siblings can be so there are some cases
where you can't paralyze
but in general we want to get to this
structure so that you can paralyze at
least the bulk of it
an interesting thing here is that rust
is actually
can express this kind of parallelism
very well
it can guarantee that basically you're
not
you're not racing on data so for example
when we do these traversals the type
system will make sure that we never
access anything but our children
as we go down the tree we can't access
siblings or our parents
which you need to make sure that you can
parallelize that otherwise you know
two sub trees that are going in parallel
could be you know racing on some
piece of data so rust helps us make
this uh safe at compile time which is
really nice
and the design of the data structure
makes it so we have some chance of
getting parallelism out of it
another thing that we just actually
finished or not finished we'll probably
never finish but
that we just sort of got the initial
version working is parallel iframes
so iframes you're probably already
already familiar with
just let you put a web page in another
web page
and there's really two cases of this in
the first case the iframes are
sort of from your own site so here we
have an outer page and it has two
iframes a blue one and a red one
they're all from the same site when
they're all from the same site
they get to interact with each other and
because they can interact with each
other you can't run them in parallel you
have to run them in the exact same
javascript runtime
so one fallout of this is if you know
the blue iframe is doing some long
calculation and now the red iframe stops
and it can't run which is not very nice
now in the cross-origin case for
security reasons these
are isolated from each other you don't
want you know if you're on a banking
website and it has an ad in it it's in
an iframe you don't want the ad to be
able to reach out and get your banking
details
so the script the the doms aren't
allowed to interact with each other
or they're only allowed to interact in
very specific isolated ways
and since that's the case we can run
these in parallel and other browsers
don't do this
they could they don't currently but
servo runs these in parallel
and actually the outer page will have
you know a script task like we saw a
layout task those will be running in
parallel we also have a rendering task
that will run in parallel
with those two and then each of these
iframes will also have a layout a script
and a rendering task
that will run in parallel
that means that if you have some heavy
computation on in the blue iframe
it won't even affect the outer page or
the or the red iframe on the other side
now html5 added this sandbox attribute
to iframes
so that you can get this kind of
security isolation even in the case
where they're on the same origin now if
you're using a sandbox iframe
it's also since we have this isolation
there's no reason we can't run them in
parallel
and so servo does that too so in the
same origin case you can also have
parallel iframes if you use the sandbox
attribute
so this is actually a new kind of
parallelism that doesn't exist currently
on the web
that we are enabling with servo i'm not
sure
you know how people will end up using
this
new feature essentially but we have some
ideas about
what people might use it for one is that
you could decode video now in javascript
because you could run the video decode
in an iframe it could show you the movie
and even if it took you know quite a bit
of cpu to decode
it was not going to affect the other
elements on the page javascript can
still execute elsewhere
you can still interact with the page
i'll show this in a demo in just a
little bit
not not video decode but with the
parallelism there
another thing is currently if you want
to get any kind of parallelism
in javascript you have to use a web
worker and web workers can't access the
dom which means that
if you're writing a game and you want to
have uh
you know do something off in another
thread which you would do in c plus
in on the web you pretty much have to do
it in a web worker but a web worker
since it can't have the dom you can't
draw to a canvas
you can't call webgl so you're pretty
restricted in what you can do
but if you have a parallel iframe you
have a dom you can call webgl you can
render textures
off in an iframe or draw on some canvas
and ship the bits back over
it'll be really interesting to see if
this is uh
gives game developers the ability to do
something new and then of course
back to the ad example if you have some
terribly behaved ad that came off an ad
network and it's running in an iframe
it won't destroy your browsing
experience like in gekko you know the
whole
browser chrome is also written in
javascript and running in the same js
runtime so
you know if one of these iframes
misbehaves like you can't even scroll or
you know you know browse to a new site
okay and then the last sort of example
is partial layout now i don't think
anyone implements partial layout in the
other browsers this is an idea that we
saw kicking around on the blink
uh mailing list and so because they were
talking about it we started talking
about you know what would it take to
implement this in servo
and it turns out that this these some of
these design decisions that we made
um we think are
are getting validated by looking at
these kinds of problems because it turns
out it makes these kinds of
optimizations very easy to make
so partial layout probably requires a
little bit of explanation
so the idea is that
if you change the property say we change
the font size on this a tag
and then we immediately say like where
is this a tag on the screen
so normally what a browser would do is
it would run all the layout calculations
for the whole tree or at least the part
of the tree that changed
and then as soon and then you know after
it's all done
it will give you the answer here's where
the a tag is but of course we can do
better than this right like
the a is pretty high up in the tree it's
possible that you know we know where it
is
relatively early in the layout
calculations so it would be nice just to
say oh
all you care about is where a is so we
figured out where a is now so let's stop
the rest of layout and we'll just hand
you back the answer
so it's a it's an easy i think it's a
relatively
straightforward thing to imagine now if
you're going to implement this in sort
of a normal
browser you have code that runs script
you have more code that runs script it
eventually gets to running layout
calculations it runs more layout
calculations so right now
basically at the end of layout then you
would you know the information would be
sent back up to the top and with
with a partial layout basically you're
just shortcutting this so
we have the answer earlier so we just
send it back up to the top earlier
but there's kind of a problem with this
in that what about this code down here
it didn't run
so we calculated this you know the
position of this a tag
and presumably some other stuff that was
around it or nearby
but there's still a whole bunch of
layout that we say didn't run yet
and now what happens is if you know we
make more changes and then we need to
lay out the page
we have to restart layout essentially
from the beginning
and we have to duplicate that work that
we already did just to get the work that
we didn't do
there's probably all kinds of ways to
fix this but it makes the control flow
really
really hairy so in servo this is a
little bit easier because we have two
different tasks running independently
that do essentially the same thing so if
layout gets the data early we can just
send
a message over to the other testing
here's the information you wanted
but crucially now it can just keep going
it can keep running and finish running
the rest of layout
and it doesn't bother the script task at
all there's no hairy control flow this
is just doing what it normally does all
day
because these are separate tasks it
makes this sort of these optimizations
really easy to realize
and we don't have to duplicate work we
don't have to make sure that the
optimization wins enough that it pays
for this cost that we paid to duplicate
this little bit of layout that we
already did
so since servo's architecture seems to
make this
much easier in fact it makes this kind
of optimization enough easier that
you know one thing you might think of is
that maybe it's worth
running script and layout concurrently
even in the case that it's not much of a
performance win
in terms of like it's not going to
double the performance but it makes the
code way simpler
so we feel i feel like this is a good
validation of some of our
early design work and there's a whole
lot of other places that we're trying to
get parallelism here
so rendering compositing and animation
we can all ship off to the gpu or at
least ship a large subset off of it to
the gpu
currently we already do rendering and
compositing on the gpu
modern browsers do compositing
a couple of them do rendering on the gpu
there's no reason they couldn't they
just
not all of them do it yet css selector
matching is an embarrassingly parallel
problem
that no one has parallelized really it's
it's still you know
academia have written sort of parallel
selector matchers and they sort of just
not trickled into the production
implementations box model solving that's
the parallel layout that we we saw
already
and just making sure all the css
calculations can get parallelized
somehow
text shaping is really interesting when
you have like a box of text you have to
figure out how big each of the words are
so you can figure out how wide the lines
are and where to break them
but each of the words is relatively
independent so you can
you know do the shaping to figure out
where they are all independently
that's actually fairly expensive to do
so it would be really nice
to be able to do it parallels should
also be sort of embarrassingly parallel
media handling i sort of talked about
you could parse html in parallel you
could parse css in parallel if you can
figure out how to do it
currently the the sort of best we have
for this is as current browsers you know
decode
images and and parse stuff off the main
thread which is about as close as
as people have gotten so far you can
also do speculation
so in when i talked earlier about how
when you're parsing an html file and you
hit a script tag you pretty much have to
stop parsing
execute the script because it might do a
document.write or
otherwise modify the dom right there you
can speculate that it's not going to do
that
and then you know keep going and then if
it does sort of undo the work
so you do extra work in some cases but
in other cases you just get done faster
and of course garbage collection is kind
of another
interesting one in the case where we
have script and layout running in
parallel
if as soon as you even if you can't even
if script has
got a block on layout as soon as you
move over to doing layout work
you might as well run the javascript
garbage collector because now you're not
doing anything else on that task
so we're trying to see how much
parallelism we can get
how fine-grained we can get it hopefully
we'll
be successful
so i wanted to show a little demo uh
so you can see that servo's working it's
not just in my imagination
let's so first
let's see if i can find this is going to
be gecko
so i'm going to show you the parallel
iframe
so what's happening here is in this
iframe
we're just running a simple animation
loop we changed the image source
of this image uh there's eight different
images and we just go in a loop changing
it
on this side we're actually multiplying
a 900 by 900 matrix so it's a
computation that's kind of expensive it
takes about two seconds to do
and you can see that you know it rests
for a while and then it'll start
multiplying these matrices and as soon
as it does you see this animation just
completely stops
and not only does the animation
completely stop but i think if i
if i try to like zoom let me find
so i can zoom here zoom in and out and
as soon as that animation stops you can
see the whole ui is unresponsive
so this is not very good
this of course is also the case in other
browsers
wow this is kind of hard to do with two
windows
and it works pretty much exactly the
same so here we stopped
finished now it's going again and it'll
stop as soon as that kicks in again
now chrome is actually a little bit
better because you know you can still
interact with the browser chrome while
this is happening and it doesn't really
affect your life too much
now let's look at servo
oops
so here's servo so we actually have an
old version of spider monkey running
here so the matrix multiplication takes
a lot longer it is happening it'll
it'll it'll take a few seconds for it to
appear but notice that
not only is the r continuing to spin
where's my mouse cursor come on oh
that's a bug
that's not a parallelism bug that's like
a date like a good old data race
um
there we go you can still zoom in while
it's going
um see if i zoom in then you can see i
can still scroll around
all while this is calculating it's
pretty much
the the sort of jankiness that you see
is just because we haven't really
written a real shell
um sorry it stopped again nice
there's a couple of bugs in it still
so but that's pretty cool right um
another thing that we can do
uh and i can't really show this in
another browser because i don't have a
working zero day exploit
but i can show you in servo because i
know how to exploit that one
so rust has tasks and tasks have sort of
this erlang model of
you can tell if they failed and it
isolates the failure
so imagine you have one of these iframes
in a browser and something bad happens
and
it fails like it triggers a bug and
layout or something and it just fails
so and you know if this is in a tab like
the whole tab will come down in chrome
in firefox it might take down the whole
browser or whatever
in an iframe even in chrome it'll take
down the whole tab
the whole page has to come down and
servo
since we run the iframes in their own
task
so here's basically the same demo and
now here's another iframe and this is a
link to a page that causes servo to
crash
and if i click it it intercepts the
crash
it just gives us an error message so we
can intercept failure for
like you know more fine-grained
components of the page
to prevent you know the rest of the page
from being effective at all
that's pretty cool like i said i'd like
to show you that in the other browsers
but i think i would
you know for starters i think it would
get me a
couple tens of thousands of dollars in
reward money
to demo a new exploit but
okay so where are we and where are we
going so we just managed to pass acid
one
so this is our ref this is our ren the
servo's rendering of acid one currently
um it's a layout focused test that
focuses a lot on
floats and and it you know all these
things with the css box model like
asymmetric borders and border sizes
and margins and padding and all that
good stuff basically if you can pass
asset one wikipedia starts to look kind
of like a regular web page
this is the reference image difference
from
our rendering you're allowed to have
differences in text rendering since
that's almost impossible to keep the
same
across platforms we thought this was
really cool so we celebrated we had a
cake made
this cake almost passes acid one itself
obviously
it doesn't have text but since that's
okay you know
uh cool so
so today we have uh we have script and
layout running concurrently
we have parallel iframes which we just
did we render on the gpu we composite on
the gpu
we are the only browser with quadtree
tile rendering so whenever we render
graphics of the screen we divide the
whole thing up into tiles
and then we manage those in a quad tree
this makes it really easy to say
find tiles that we should evict from
memory uh when we're scrolling or
something
to make room for new tiles they're you
know close in some sense
it's easy to find tiles that are far
away and close we have basic navigation
it's you know we hit the bat you hit
backspace to go backwards and shift
backspace to go forwards
which i thought was really silly until i
realized that's what all the other
browsers did too
we have basic dom apis now we just
started adding these
uh we have you know set attribute create
element a pin child
some of those you were able to see in
the demo we still have a lot of dom api
implementation stuff to do
and it works on linux mac and and
sometimes on android we haven't got the
android one
in our continuous integration system so
it gets broken a lot but
that should be fixed fairly soon and in
the future
these are the things i mean i told you
about most of the stuff we're hoping to
layout uh hoping to accomplish like
parallel layouts a big one
incremental layout where we only
recalculate the layout for the pieces of
the dom that have changed
is a really important one part of the
problem here is that you know we want to
have benchmarks like how good are we
compared to firefox or safari or ie
and you have to do a huge amount of
engineering work just to get to the
point where you can do a test that's
reasonable right like
you know one of the original tests that
we tried to do was you know set some dom
property in a loop and then immediately
ask for where it is on the screen so now
you have to go through the whole script
layout
cycle and time that and then we found
out gekko was way faster than us and
when we investigated we found out that
it was basically a no op in gekko
because it was optimizing it out
and so then we made the test slightly
worse and then we found okay well
gekko's only you know recalculating some
very small part of the layout tree and
we recalculate the whole layout tree
every time
so we have to implement all this stuff
just to get to the point where we can
make some kind of comparison to figure
out if our work is
in the right direction we're very
serious about making this embeddable uh
you know gecko isn't easy to embed uh
webkit was
and webkit got embedded everywhere like
servo we plan to make embeddable from
the start
js manage dom is kind of hard to explain
but essentially all the dom data
structures are
you know native code data structures
they're c plus objects in
gecko in servo they're rust objects and
javascript needs to be able to talk to
them so they have these little wrappers
that allow the js engine to talk to the
c plus object
it turns out it's too expensive to just
create these wrappers all the time
so you create them lazily so most dom
nodes never get accessed from javascript
so it's expense it's so expensive like
it's a tiny little piece of memory right
but it's still expensive enough to
allocate this
rapper that you don't want to do it so
we're we're we have some new ideas for
how to do that we're working with the
spider monkey team to to do that
um we're we're currently using netsurf
css which is a c library for
style sheet parsing and and um doing
doing um the cascade uh we're
we're rewriting that all in rust right
now um and then we're
pretty soon we'll be able to have some
actual benchmarks and
we have almost enough dom stuff to start
running the conformance test to find out
you know which pieces of
the dom apis we conform to and lastly
i would love for you guys to help us
build servo we can't do this by ourself
if you interested in rust and don't have
a project yourself to work on
uh servo's written in rust come please
come help us
you can program in a new language making
significant contributions to a new web
browser
i have a whole list of projects there's
a list in the bug tracker on github
of things marked easy so if you're not
sure about how web browsers are
implemented you're just interested or
you're just
looking to have some fun there's a lot
of cool stuff to do there
you can find us on github we hang out in
pound servo on the mozilla irc server
there's a mailing list if you want to
just follow along and
lurk and see what we're up to and if you
have any questions for me i'm on twitter
at
meta jack and there's my email address
thanks
you